organic is not a matter of belief
organic is codified regulated and its
definition is established by the
Department of Agriculture so in the
United States organic means vegetable
crops that are produced under conditions
in which there's no fertilizers no
artificial pesticides and they're not
genetically modified irradiated or
fertilized with sewage sludge very clear
definition animals must be fed organic
feed they must be allowed access to the
outdoors and there are some other rules
that that define that and in order to
for a company to get a certified organic
seal on their product they must follow
those rules and be inspected to make
sure they follow those rules and almost
everybody that I know who was involved
in the organic industry says the rules
are followed there's very little
cheating and that in fact the system is
pretty tight in following the rules the
big question is whether those rules make
any sense or not and whether they're
good enough strong enough and meaningful
enough with the most obvious loophole
being the one about animals having
access to the outdoors the rule doesn't
say they have to be outdoors the rule
just says they have to have access to
the outdoor
that's a loophole
you